fast forward to now obviously we know
what happened
a year and a half ago i think was was a
year and a half ago two years ago when
president trump
uh helped you uh uh you know get your
rank back you he gave you a phone call i
think he called you and
spoke to you about what took place would
you mind sharing with the audience
some of the events that took place uh
two years ago when you got that phone
call
sure so i mean i'll try and uh sum it up
as best i can uh you know i i like i
said my last uh deployment was to mosul
in 2017.
we were directed to uh annihilate isis
out of missoula
um it's a great deployment uh we
successful deployment we did clear
missile in time um and uh unfortunately
there was four
three to four guys in my platoon
who we did not get along they were
younger guys it was their first time in
combat um i think they
their eyes were opened especially on
that deployment it was pretty uh chaotic
but uh i think they realized that
this job wasn't for them but instead of
taking ownership of that they
pointed the finger at me and pretty much
were saying i put them in harm's way i
made them
you know go out all the time and do do
their job um and you know their their
complaints
were pretty petty uh they went to my
command after the deployment with these
complaints and the command told them
that these were not
real complaints and to move on
so they kept escalating their
allegations when they weren't getting
the attention they wanted so that it
turned in from i was
dangerous to i was a thief
of course they had nothing to back it up
for being a thief
and i think the command finally told
them like listen either you guys
move on or come you know come back with
something that's
uh legit and so about six months later
they came back and had said that i had
stabbed an isis prisoner to death
and they had it on video
[Music]
the command bought their lie uh i'm not
sure if the command ever asked to see
the video or not but because the video
never existed
but the command uh bought off on it um
told them to report it to ncis and so
once ncis uh took the
allegations and turned it into an
investigation that's where this thing
really went off the rails uh we
they had a corrupt agent ncis agent
named joe warpinski took the case um
very young
and ambitious but also very incompetent
and
he pretty much formed a prosecution
before he started investigating and he
pretty much took whatever little pieces
of information he could to
you know throw it throw at me during the
investigation and then anything that
cleared my name he would he would hide
which you know we would find out during
this process but uh
it was an eye-opener um you know as soon
as i was accused or not even acute like
the rumors were out there that i had
killed an isis prisoner it was i was
guilty until proven innocent i was told
that by my command
they pretty much shunned me uh they
you know put me in an office and told me
to sit there and we'll they wait to see
where this thing goes
um while i was you know sitting in that
office for about a month they uh raided
my house ncis came um
they were staking me out for about two
weeks
they came in right in my house while my
wife and i were not home pulling my two
youngest or my two boys out at gunpoint
in their underwear and then laid siege
to my house that's when
we knew my wife and i knew this thing
was uh off the rails um but you know we
didn't know what to do at the time um i
had so shortly after they had raided my
house i had moved my family to florida
and then i was going to geo batch uh for
my final year until i retired
um
they waited for me to come back uh after
moving my family to florida and i went
to a uh
tbi clinic a traumatic brain injury
clinic to get checked up uh
it's a normal procedure for guys who are
about to retire to get checked up for
all their injuries during their uh
career
and i was about a week into that went in
they came and arrested me
and threw me in a military prison with
no charges
no explanation why i was being thrown in
prison they just said they had orders
from uh
admiral greene who was the uh
the admiral in charge of uh war com at
the time and then also signed off by uh
commander rosenblum who was the
commodore of group one for naval special
warfare
um
any do you know any reason why they
arrested you on 9 11.
uh yeah 11 2018 what was the reason
behind that was that like a message i
mean you know you could do 9 12 9 10 9
11 is 9 11.
exactly everything they do and this is
what i learned through this process so
all these actions they took against me
are done on purpose
them raiding my house without myself my
wife there was to enrage me and also to
break up my family and also to put shame
on our family which worked because our
neighbors
were like oh they just don't do that to
people unless you did something
and then uh during uh
when i was at the tvi clinic they chose
september 11th for that specific reason
because they know that day means a lot
to us who have been serving the past 20
years and they thought that would make
me snap and i would do something
obviously i'm a lot smarter than that i
just i complied i thought i was like
this is a big mistake
and i thought that you know in my mind i
was like this is a big mistake you guys
uh this will be fixed but as i came to
find out once you're thrown in military
prison
even as a pre-trial prisoner um you are
not getting out at all until your trial
date and
once they throw you in there they just
keep pushing your trial date back and
back and back hoping you'll take a plea
deal so you know
the video that you say that they sent to
ncis and for audience that doesn't know
what ncis is ncis is uh
it's the intelligence organization right
it's it's uh the what does nci stand for
naval criminal investigative service
yeah naval criminal investigation okay
so once it goes there there was one
video that was circulating what was that
one video with the body that was limp
and you apologize for that one video i
don't know what they had john was that
on 60 minutes there was somewhere i saw
a video with you
so body
there's pictures so what they did when
they raided my house uh they had they
took
they took all my phones everything um
and uh there was a picture
of me posing with a dead isis fighter uh
along with uh 12 other people in my
pretend
and also i had sent a text message uh
to a buddy of mine
during that deployment as a joke um with
that picture saying good story behind
this got him with a honey knife
that was a
dark humor um i but i'll tell you what
that that was the best and worst piece
of evidence they had against me um
you know it was the worst because
obviously it makes me look
pretty guilty uh but if you you know
zoom in on the picture and look there's
no blood on the knife there's no blood
on me there's no blood anywhere no no uh
uh
nothing that shows this guy's been
stabbed uh
but they took that text message and that
picture and that's that was their main
piece of evidence they're like we got
him and that's they were going around
telling everybody they had me dead to
rights like he's guilty
he's going away
but they had also since these um younger
guys in my platoon had said there was a
video
they were you know they were spreading
that rumor as well saying like because
they the judge had put a gag order on
all the evidence so you we weren't
allowed to show the evidence to anybody
and neither was the prosecution or they
they weren't supposed to but as we come
came to find out they were given
whatever evidence they wanted to the
media um to sort of smear my name
but uh
eventually we got the judge uh to let us
show the video to congress um because
that lie had gone all the way up to the
white house saying there was a video of
me doing uh this act and so once we were
able to show the actual video to members
of congress and whoever else it was they
quickly realized that they had been lied
to by the navy
and that's where you know their case
started crumbling so if you like this
sort of short club from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you